[Musica]
siamo pesci che nuotano nelle storie
siano talmente dentro le storie che a
volte non ce ne rendiamo conto
non so se vi rendete conto appunto che
abbiamo appena sentito delle storie in
cui il protagonista principale era il
lievito e lo yogurt e da lì s'andava
all'idea di far tornare sulla terra i
mammut che mi manda fuori di testa
l'idea e raymond moody mi piace un sacco
anche lo yogurt però con ladri scorso
siamo immersi nelle storie viviamo
nelson e storie che ci raccontiamo ci
permettono di capire qual è il limite ci
permettono di cambiare quei limiti
attraverso le storie che ci raccontiamo
tra di noi
proprio di recente l'università di
florida che hanno fatto una una
grandissima convention per capire quali
sono le storie come si fa a raccontare
le cose complesse le cose grandi le cose
importanti le cose di che stiamo adesso
vivendo e la domanda era anche come si
fa a raccontare no libris nell'era dello
story telling e io personalmente non
c'ero al convegno umano invitato non so
perché però però una cosa la so di
sicuro che quando mi faccio queste
domande qui io vado sempre a cercare la
risposta tra gli antichi o sempre tra
quelli che adesso si chiamano i classici
ma per me sono gli antichi perché sono
come gli antenati di casa sono come mio
nonno e ovidio stato se ne stanno lì che
bevono ombra di vino insieme fanno
questa cosa per me quella è sempre la
fonte
allora prendiamo ad esempio il classico
caso di tracotanza che bella parola
tracotanza era dalle medie che non la
sentivo
il classico e il volo di icaro no più o
meno da e la sappiamo un po tutti però
diciamo il problema delle storie che
sono vive le storie per tagliarle hai
bisogno delle forbici molecolari perché
sono vive sono catene che vanno dai
tempi antichi arrivano oggi diciamo che
la taglio io arbitrariamente tagliamola
al papa di caro that al più grande
ingegnere architetto scienziato di atene
che però era malato di libri se appena
trova un allievo che minaccia di
superarlo lo uccide allora deve scappare
da atene e dove scappa a creta dove lo
aspetta a braccia aperte minosse il re
di creta che non vedeva l'ora di avere
uno scienziato così grande e al suo
servizio chissà quali grandi cose gli
può far fare minosse è la prima cosa che
gli chiedono
in realtà è la moglie di minosse dedalo
si è innamorata di un toro ed è talmente
innamorata perché è stato zeus
ovviamente a farla innamorare di quel
toro quando gli dei vogliono fanno
quello che vogliono loro
e allora si è innamorata di un toro e
gli chiede di costruire un corpo di
cortesia
diciamo un robot a forma di vacca per
permetterle di godersi questo amplesso e
ovviamente cosa puoi fare sei ospite io
l'ho fatta io fabbrica questo
meraviglioso corpo di vacca meccanico
lei dentro fa questo amplesso innaturale
con il toro è ovviamente nasce un mostro
è che il mostro è il minotauro con la
testa di toro il corpo di uomo questo
giovanetto che ricorda a minosse che
anche lui a suo modo alle corna non
piace il minotauro è un divoratore di
carne umana oltretutto perché un toro un
po particolare quindi va messo al sicuro
allora che cosa fa minosse va bene tu
hai creato il problema
lo risolvi fame un labirinto in cui
mettere dentro questo mostro enorme e
lui lo fa dal grande fa un labirinto
straordinario il suo capolavoro quello
che l'ha reso famoso fino a oggi fa un
labirinto in cui le prospettive cambiano
completamente di dondi secondo il
secondo i punti di riferimento non sono
mai gli stessi gira come il fiume
meandro e limpido meandro che torna
spesso su se stesso e rigira con le sue
acque chiare va verso se stesse si
incontra e poi si perde è talmente
intricato il labirinto di dedalo che
persino dedalo fa fatica a uscirne ma
quando esce disagio l'aqua fatto è
minossi bravo complimenti
chi è che sta il segreto di questo
labirinto solo io
perfetto dentro e lo ammette
imprigionato dentro il labirinto che ha
costruito uno scienziato intrappolato
nella sua invenzione molto simbolico e
lo tiene dentro il tempo necessario a
generare un figlio
dentro questo labirinto il figlio e
icaro evidentemente passava agente era
un labirinto che passava la gente ci
andava era no
[Applauso]
basta che se no che dopo c'è il time map
con la casa il rito la verità il
probabile evidente perché c'era un sacco
di persone lui fa un figlio e un figlio
di cui si affeziona cui io come tutti i
padri non finisci per affezionarti al
bambino allora incomincia a pensare
questo bambino come lo faccio uscire da
qua come faccio andare via da sto posto
me faccio farlo crescere dentro un
labirinto al centro del quale c'è un
minotauro devo fare qualcosa e poi se
esco se esco dal labirinto che questo ce
la posso fare
ma se esco dall abilità sono i soldati
di minosse se poi ci sono c'è il mare e
poi dove vado il mare i soldati
certo il celo celo non c'è nessuno ce lo
è aperto il cielo è di tutti potrei come
faccio per andare in cielo cioè non
abbiamo la tecnologia dai aspetti penso
su un genio ci pensa ci penso sono un
genio
fra un favore va a giocare di lauro per
papa sta pensando per formigaro la
smetti di giocare col e più mete dei
gabbiani che vola al per favore basta
cioè di ovvio come ho fatto non pensarci
prima
mi faccio un e ali con le piume che
cadevano dal cielo evidentemente
labirinto era aperto che cadevano dal
cielo le mette in fila
ce lo dicono gli antichi anche come fa
se volete provare a casa mette prima
prima le le penne più piccole poi sempre
più grandi sempre più lunga sempre più
lunghezza tanto che sembra un un rustico
flauto come quelli che per quelli di voi
che se li ricordano suonavano gli inti
illimani siamo in quattro
e questa e poi le lega con un filo e poi
con la cera le connette queste ali e poi
le mette le indossa con un sistema di
cinghie comincia a sbattere le ali
sbatte le ali e si trova sospeso
nell'aria incredulo col bambino
ciò che balla tutto contento e lui
allora scende e ne fa un altro paio per
suo figlio
e mentre glielo fa suo figlio gioca con
la cera non rendendosi conto che sta
giocando con una roba pericolosa per un
bambino e lui mi fa queste ha lette
anche per lui e poi gli elementi mentre
gli elementi come un papà come una mamma
mi fa tutte le raccomandazioni hai fatto
la pipì
sì mi raccomando che non si sa che dopo
stiamo volando ti scappa dover tornare
indietro
e poi cosa gli fa gli lega li legga le
ali e gli dice mi raccomando icaro non
volare troppo vicino all'acqua l'umidità
appesantisce le piume non volare troppo
in alto
se ti avvicini troppo al sole il sole
scioglie la cera e cadrai devi stare nel
giusto mezzo uno scienziato che dice
molto simbolico secondo me e partono e
partono come un uccello che scende
dall'alto nido per la prima volta fa
volare i suoi piccoli così è dedalo che
vola sbattendo le ali ma è più
preoccupato di quello che vuole ha
dietro di dove sta andando
continua a preoccuparsi e gli urla
consigli mi raccomando in alto sta pian
piano piano sbatti sbatte e pian piano
anche suo figlio vola sul figlio vuole
allora si dirigono verso la sicilia
perché lì dicono che ci sia un re buono
che li accoglie rai forse li difenderà
anche dall'ira di minosse vanno verso la
sicilia ma mentre vanno poi c'è un
cambio di prospettiva bellissimo in un
video mentre vanno cioè un contadino
poca roba
scusate proprio cretese questo robot e
per mary prima linea reby tremendo cosa
sono queste creature non possono essere
che dei non possono essere che dei
questi questi due alati che volano e il
piccolo il dicono che pian piano icaro
ha preso familiarità allora volo attorno
al papa smetti laica non fa il cretino
iker d'asta indietro poi va sopra il
guardaroba
faccio una picchiata fa il deficiente
viene su nenè soda dopo la picchiata
comincia a salire ed è bello è bello
salire sale sempre di più sempre di più
sempre di più che tanto non sente
neanche più il suo padre che gli laica
va fin troppo vicino al sole e come
previsto come era stato scritto il sole
caldo scioglie la cera cadono le piume e
senza più niente con cui remy gare icaro
cade urlando il nome del padre e cade
finché l'acqua azzurra non ne frena la
caduta il padre deve cercarlo e l'unica
cosa che trova sono più me
c'è stato un film di hollywood sarebbe
stata diversa
la trama primo il finale non era così
finale era il vecchio padre che si
sacrificava eroicamente lanciando al
volo le ali al figlio che cadeva lui le
prendeva il vecchio moriva il giovane
capiva i suoi errori e andava avanti
diventando il più grande scienziato del
mondo presidente gli stati uniti
d'america
forse fosse stata la oliver fosse stata
al non avremmo visto menzioni a vacche
meccaniche
forse è stata alle a dedalo non avrebbe
ucciso per invidia per gelosia per i
brees avrebbe ucciso per errore mentre
sperimentavano una macchina che doveva
salvare l'umanità ma non era lì sono i
greci antichi sono i latini sono gente
che invece con libris trafficava
quotidianamente e come te la raccontano
questa roba grande se guardate cioè
proprio c'è una specie di formula è la
formula è si parla di persone non
parlano mai
l'arroganza la tracotanza parlando di
persone della storia di persone parlano
per immagini immagini chiare il fiume
meandro leali il gabbiani
il contadino che guarda e si stupisce
dice questi non sono uomini sono dei a
chiarire delle cose lasciano un sacco di
roba in silenzio per permettere a te che
stai ascoltando la storia di riempire i
silenzi con le cose in cui credi tu così
sembra che la storia stia parlando di te
e si mettono sempre sempre nelle scarpe
dell'altro le indossano i panni sempre
sembra che abbiamo fatto un master alla
university of florida
challenge cammina e kai qin san giorgio
però se un greci e latini e il punto è
che ti raccontano una storia senza farti
la morale da nessuna parte in questa
storia se andate a vedervi la da nessuna
parte si dice perché vedano
mai anche perché provate a leggerla
anche voi andate a vedere per la trans
la trovate e da nessuna parte capisci
bene dove comincia libris dove finisce
dov'è la nemesi di chi è la nemesi la
vendetta
l'eccesso di chi è di minosse che
pensate di essere superiori agli dei e
di dedalo che siccome fa le cose
artificiali artefatte allora ha superato
la natura e di icaro che in punta al
sole quando tutti gli hanno detto di non
farlo dov'è libri se dove e chi è stato
punito
questa è la bellezza del racconto tu
questo racconto lo puoi portare in
qualsiasi contesto la puoi mettere
ovunque questa cosa io stesso ho dovuto
tagliarla per raccontarvela perché sennò
dovevo andare indietro fino al caos
primordiale e andare avanti fino a
vedere leonardo i fratelli wright il
primo volo nello spazio il led zeppelin
[Musica]
qualcuno la capitale
allora io chiudo qui la storia finisce
qui finisce non è vero perché dedalo
continuava in sicilia di succedono cose
minosse e minotauro brutte a minotauro
ma quello che voglio dirvi io e io non
ho nessuna intenzione far morale perché
se non lo facevano loro perché dovrei
farlo io però certo c'è in questa
struttura portatile universale c'è una
roba che ci possiamo così dire tra di
noi per salutarci quelle in conclusione
il momento so what del tedax c'è e il
momento è le storie secondo me dicono
che libris questa specie di arroganza
questa specie di irrequietudine che non
ti permette mai di stare dentro i tuoi
limiti è proprio quello che significa
essere umani questo ti raccontano le
storie libris significa essere umano
voler sempre uscire dal limite voler
sempre non essere né dio né uomo né
animale una roba un mostro
quasi e l'altra cosa che ci dicono
sempre le storie quando raccontano
questa storia qui è che a essere così si
paga sempre un prezzo ogni volta che
passi il limite paghi un prezzo sempre
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]